[Applause]
[Music]
i thank all the cities that took part
in the first access city award under
this commission's mandate
the high number of applications is
impressive this
shows the clear interest of european
mayors and their administrations for
their cities
to become more accessible and thereby
inclusive
better accessibility means that a city
improves
the lives of persons with disabilities
but not only
many others can experience the benefits
of accessibility
[Music]
undoubtedly 2020 is a year we will all
remember
the crisis we are going through has
focused our attention on the critical
role
of public services including on their
accessibility
so to make the efforts of these cities
even more visible we called for a
special prize on
accessibility of public services in
times of the pandemic to complement
the usual award i have the pleasure to
announce already
that six cities have been recognized for
their outstanding efforts in terms of
accessibility
they are bremerhaven in germany ferenza
italy
gdenia poland yon shopping sweden
comatini greece and poznan and poland
these cities are now more accessible and
i congratulate
all those who worked towards this aim
i look forward to announcing the names
of the laureates
at the excess city awards 2021 ceremony
on the 1st of december i hope that
you will all virtually attend the
ceremony
and follow the european day of persons
with disabilities conference
[Music]
you